goosebumps is one of the best-selling
book series of all time
and this man is responsible for each and
every terrifying spine-tingling
horror-filled story
hi i'm r.l stein i write the goosebumps
books huh maybe he's not so scary i
actually started as a humor writer
well what do you know
in 1992 scholastic released the very
first goosebumps book but way before
that a young bob stein was into writing
jokes i started writing funny stuff when
i was nine years old all i ever wanted
to be was funny
when i came to new york i had my own
humor magazine and after 10 years i
thought gee i've done what i always
wanted to do i guess i'll coast the rest
of my life i had no idea what was in
store for me and then
things started to get spooky i had lunch
with the editorial director at
scholastic she had a fight with a y.a
horror writer and she said you could
write a good why a horror novel he said
okay no problem you got it and i went
home and
wrote this novel and it was a number one
bestseller i thought whoa wait a minute
forget the funny stuff
and i've been scary ever since that book
marked the start of r.l stein's horror
writing career and he eventually wrote
an entire series called goosebumps but
it wasn't an immediate success
they went out and they just sat on the
shelves they didn't sell two months goes
by three months nothing we figured
that's it didn't work out and then
something happened it's a mystery kids
discovered it somehow
nobody knew me really there was no hype
no advertising no publicity there was
nothing just kids telling kids it's just
you know one of these amazing lucky
things that happened
now after 25 years goosebumps is scaring
a whole new generation of kids it's a
really nice thing to be able to write
for different generations at first i was
shocked when adults started showing up
in my book signings i'd say what are you
doing here
say we loved you when we were kids and i
realized
i'm nostalgia to them i think you kind
of remember that tingle of fear that you
had when you were a kid
but with the success of goosebumps does
rl stein ever miss the chance to be
funny there's something weird with my
brain because horror always makes me
laugh it's that same visceral reaction
that's what i try to do in my books
people think if you're a horror writer
you're scary all the time and your whole
life is horror but i did my own late
night comedy show at upright citizens
brigade last year
are you doing one this year too i'm
waiting by the phone no one's called me
i don't know
i'm waiting
[Music]
that was it that might be my comedy
career
[Music]
you